some various junk that from the front
looks like this and the world's first
orange alligator it's episode 19 of IMG
a new Kinect trick allows you to take
photos with your xbox and then build
them in Minecraft and here's some true
tetris love when your car gets covered
in snow let the snow people drive it and
then with a little creativity proved
that money is the root of all evil
zombies and why spray paint all
willy-nilly when you could paint each
individual brick and make a pixelated
link if Guido was on the Jersey Shore it
would suck but this really blows awesome
oh oh this is how pumpkin pie is made
maybe you'd prefer some Star Wars cakes
or TV dinner cupcakes but before you
wash it all down this is why drinking is
like yoga this issue of Parents magazine
is old and photoshopped but covering
letters always makes places more fun
especially if it's accidental Ted
Williams had an awesome weekend to
celebrate here are some equally awesome
homeless signs enjoy
[Music]
now it's time for the worst parenting
ever
we've got grocery shopping party time
snakes pole dancing lessons champagne
and hey you look angry take this right
now it's Jesus but upside down it's
Satan and where's the human covered in
paint oh there is there he is
but where is he here well this is true
okay let's look at some hilariously
inappropriate t-shirts wrong strategy
wrong age wrong everything and thanks
for the warning here's a great vanity
plate and she is pretty
who else was she ball on Facebook you
guys are still at it
Ryan Tim brought us hard rock and he
also brought us a most nutritious
breakfast to see more and submit your
favorites like us over at facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaming and I'll leave you
today with my favorite actual questions
that were really asked on Yahoo Answers
let me know below what question you
would most want answered and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]